si possono mettere le bandiere ma si
serie ovviamente non posso che mettere
la bandiera dell'isola di capo verde
perché l'isola di capo verde mi
rappresentano a tutti ragazzi è ben vero
dove sono video sono fa vj viaggi sono
tornati su rocket league è uno dei miei
giochi preferiti da un secolo a questa
parte su pc e fantastico senza partiti
dove cazzo è finito conto alla rovescia
dove sono le buone maniere non mancò
joystick suoi eterni aiuto star di no e
scollegato [ __ ] nove fermi stranzi
vice ci siamo ci siamo effetto vice
neanche neanche il tempo di brand grazie
ragazzi in fair play questo chiuderà il
mio compagno con la corona lì che c'è in
te tela infiliamo tutta su per la
marmitta e voglia siamo partiti di merda
ma continueremo in modo giusto la siamo
3 a 0 stiamo perdendo
adesso tutti i gol nieri tranne questo
questo qua era parco no scherza era per
dargli un po di vantaggio perché sennò
vincerei troppo facile per lo start no
da rega link a quello che esplode ma si
può essere più [ __ ] ed i gol 14
perfetto dai dai che ce la facciamo noi
che ci facciamo forza forza
porca [ __ ] timori se la famiglia non
fare tre gol prima che finisse la
partita ma ce la farò lo sento
cioè io l'ho ragazzi l'ho presa
veramente così è madonna 2 lato corona
il cazzo avete morire troppa fortuna
roba lega non c'era che vado a quel
lager del pazzo aiuto che laghi e fermi
che ha posto zio ben rye jinbei jim
watson in putrefazione morta che
qualcuno che la tocca bravo zio michè a
un assist che ho fatto che che è servito
bravo cazzo mi rende orgoglioso mi ha
stuprato la palla no no bastardi
ma fai qualcosa nella tua inutile vita
del cazzo falla io sto decidendo la
partita per la mia squadra e mi laga
come la merda ma si può ma guarda fermi
calmi è impossibile dai santo gesù no
arrivato beh vabbè ho capito dio quanto
odio la mia connessione di merda se
volevo una da zero senza 10 a 4 in
partenza questa volta senza lag che
sarebbe gradito grazie a fare una
partita seria se la mamma bravo bravo e
chi è che segna chi che segna zio chi è
chi segna ops no non toccarla non
toccano lati stupro il cane 6 anche il
mio compagno lurido non toccarla se ti
dico non toccarla bravo
non è gol ancora tu sei vero mi spiace
adesso ma come la devi togliere se segno
compagno ignota alla nostra ma che cazzo
fai
ma chi vota a marzo la famiglia ti giuro
alta ammazzo ti vengo a trovare in nepal
e ti ammazzo ma perché vestire un cazzo
ma per eventi di nella squadra blu ok ma
perché non si può stare ma [ __ ] 10
e 11 semmai che a riprova ragazzi è no
c'è proprio un ragazzi traverso stravino
che cazzo c'è fuori ma è buio bellissimo
che buio 20 0 la porta e quella dobbiamo
segnare di da bravi ragazzi bravi
ok ed hegel no l'ha toccata per l'isola
di capo verde ma [ __ ] da roba
strana liste gioca lega che non si
capisce un cazzo quando si parte ok
perfetto otto catello fantastico la cosa
mi rifiuto di credere a questa cosa ok
non toccate la vas carta gol gol gol gol
miu miu miu a sucate sucate tutti ve la
palla dove la palla ecco la hell's bells
sarà mica gol cate tutti vedo sempre
giocare con dei cerebrolesi non è
possibile tutta la butta la punta alla
bocca e del gg di turno che la para
mamma sara gol di nuovo magari il film
ha detto no dai tir a tiro 6 a porta
vuota bravo
mica se non segnava agosto arti ma ne ha
la palla servita sempre male anche pippo
inzaghi e toccarono toccarla per di qua
non toccare bravo ok e con le gole gol e
gol e sono 41 tre gol e un assist
ragazzi sono in due nella mia squadra
oltre me non fanno un cazzo
mamma mia guardate chi l'ha toccata con
l'ali chi segna ma dai
chi come con che fisica è tornata
indietro spiegatelo a mille ragazzi
fanno ed è gol
tutti a [ __ ] eva ma no spam fino a
quando segnerò di sciabola l'amica 30
secondi mi bastano ragazzi mi bastano
ragazzi abbiamo portato il nome è
l'ossimoro neanche più
cosa hanno preso la traversa non ci
credo e largo con lo schifo e ragazza
non la classica ci siamo ecco la justin
sei pronto so che anche tu supporti capo
verde forza justin buttano in mezzo da
stendeva cazzo palo ma dai punto la
puntata puntata e mezzo qualcuno siamo
in quattro qualcuno che la butti dentro
an possibile paralisi fan justin bieber
justin fucking quale si era una 11
scusate ma per tutti che ballano forza
mai qualcuno che la bua
ok ok bravo luca
quattro a uno di ha vinto ma è bravo ed
è 51 voldemort ha assegnato ragazzi io e
volte molto abbiamo un atto tutta la
partita perfetta ragazzi dai facciamo
un'ultima contro uno solo uno contro uno
vediamo che esce fuori questa ragazza è
classificata quindi melo segna nelle
classifiche sera vincola perdo quindi
speriamo di vincere sono contro uno che
si chiama this set che avrà di sicuro
meno lag di me i fatti che [ __ ]
semiprofessionista sei certo zio come
stai intanto madre brutta non importa
avere la macchina bella ma saperla
guidare star
ecco bravo imbarchi ciao ed è forse gol
per fa vj attenzione se ladri no
bastardo assista solo e solchi a lo sto
anche facendo il video visto che bravo
la tua professionalità andrà su youtube
non ci credo pensi muoversi preso pago
addio
ciao ho preso milano marco ciao come
stai
la porta e questa era dovresti parare la
palla invece no invece si cazzola presa
a mi chiamo fa vj ciao sono le l'isola
di capo verde cia non lo faccio sempre
mai
non è invece ho segnato io regalo
perfetto che gol ho fatto che abbiamo
sbagliato porta zio scusa e credevo
fosse atom va bene dai zio 2 a 1 te lo
concedo non ti concedo più gol pero mar
agri cosa fa a pressione succhia 3 a 1
semiprofessionista dove nel mio anno e
c'è uno che rappa di sottofondo fa vj al
mike faccio tutti i gol sono tanti
partenza e tu che sposti la credenza ci
abbiamo provato ragazzi ma non ci siamo
riusciti a quando non ho è mio
bastardo ma la foto ma io segno uguale
bravo braunau non ci credo cosa
ciao sono fa vj sono di capo verde
l'inizio era abbandonato la partita se
abbiamo vinto 5 1 contro
semiprofessionista complimenti ho vinto
la bandiera di tweet a causa manco fossi
in lei dov'era una live sto gioco prima
o poi mi piace un casino d'accordo
ragazzi che includono episodio anche
perché sennò milio troppa gente mi
dispiace quindi ragazzino va beh è una
figata un che io lo adoro rocket league
non trovo il telecomando dove cazzo
ammesso vabbè chiudo con questo arrivi
di ragazzi spero che amino mi sia
piaciuto e cosa sento seguite più
giocato al momento mi piace anche la
pace di facebook e condivido tratta
descrizione so se avessi di stranieri
come ho detto ci vediamo un proseguito
belle ragazze